- I did not know that you
had a house in Wyoming.
I didn't know that you
lived in Wyoming as well.
I live in Montana as well.
- Yeah, yeah. - I have a ranch in Montana.
So I didn't know that you
had a place in Wyoming.
I didn't.
You like it up there?
You like the snow? All that.
- Yeah. I knew about your ranch,
but you didn't know about mine.
What's
- I didn't.
I am the worst.
I literally just went to dinner last night
and like found out all this
information from friends.
I don't know things
cause I'm not on social media.
Like I'm on like,
I put stuff out and say like,
"Hey, post this" or something,
but I'm not on it.
Cause I saw Social
Dilemma and I freaked out.
- Yeah, we're the same
people. I'm the same way.
- I don't wanna be that tapped in.
- Nope. Don't wanna be that tapped in.
I don't wanna be tracked
every five minutes.
I don't want people to
know everything I'm doing.
Oh, I'm having breakfast.
Look at my sandwich.
What are we doing here?
- Yeah, yeah.
- But no Jackson for me is, is,
I mean it's God's country.
Big open sky. Fresh air.
I love the snow.
I love being visited by
the animals and the views.
- [Kelly] Cute town.
- The Teton.
Yeah. Cute town. Yeah, yeah.
- I noticed in your picture.
I was like, "Oh my God, I've been there."
It's beautiful.
I took, I went to Montana
rather than Wyoming.
It's a little less as cold
as it gets where you are.
Yeah. It's real cold where you go.
- It's real cold.
I'm actually looking to go
to Colorado next because
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah?
- Yeah. As much as I love Jackson,
I wanted more space and just,
I like being alone.
I'm a loner by nature.
I love being alone.
- Me too.
Everybody thinks that you have to like,
and I'm like I enjoy my alone time
because I feel like we're surrounded.
- [Tyler] All day.
- Not, not just in the industry.
If you're a teacher, if
you're whatever you do,
we're always surrounded by people.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's nice to be alone.
And that's, I only have one kid though.
- Okay, I have two.
- Yeah. Which is a lot for me.
Two is a lot.
- Well, when you have two,
they start to play together.
- That's exactly.
- Then you have time to pee alone.
- Yeah, that's exactly.
That's, that's, yep.
That's exactly right.
You're right. Yeah.
But I'm one and done for me, but yeah.
But no, I, I love, I
love being in Jackson.
I love the fresh air.
I love it all.
- Oh, man. It's so nice.
I hear that you,
I have moose on my property.
You have moose, as well?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Your moose
- Well, we're on their property.
- That's true.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Well, it's
all borrowed property.
We're gonna, we're all
terminal at some point.
Yeah.
- [Tyler] 100%.
- But no, my moose,
they stay like in like the wooded
- I love you call it your moose.
That you
- No, my moose. I own them. - Yeah.
- No, no I just mean,
I see them in like the woods.
I don't, they don't ever
come up to my house,
but yours like literally
like sit in front of
your door.
- Oh, no. Yeah.
In front of the door.
I was, the first time I ever saw one
- [Kelly] They're dangerous.
- Yeah. They very dangerous.
I was working out in the gym.
The garage doors were open.
I'm working out and this
huge shadow passed by.
And I go, "What is that?"
It's this moose, moose.
He's about nine feet tall,
with the antlers and everything.
- Rack is huge.
- I was like, "Oh, my gosh."
But yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah, they're terrifying.
- And there's a place
where I sit and write
around a little fire pit and they love it.
- Yeah.
- He'll go out there
and he's tearing up the chairs and all.
So I'm like, "Listen, you were here first.
You could have it.
I'll just stay up here in the house."
I'm not going out there.
Yeah. - [Kelly] Not going near that chair.